I would not have been able to
play this role had I not understood love
of a tremendous magnitude and for that I
thank my family my mother live Tanner
who I am
love more than anything and my brother
Jake Paltrow who is just the dearest
person in the whole world my Earthly
Guardian Angel Mary Wigmore
and especially to my father Bruce
Paltrow who has surmounted
insurmountable obstacles this year
to my grandpa Buster a grandpa I want I
want you to know that you've created a
beautiful family who loves you and loves
each other more than anything and we
thank you for that
I would like to dedicate this to two
young men who lost their lives very
early
Harrison kravis and my cousin Keith
Paltrow we miss you very much and I
thank you thank you so much everybody
foreign